so i'm pleased to introduce the genuine
article not a
not any drop nothing off of twitter the
genuine article
one of the hosts the first take on espn
our friend stephen a smith back here on
the rich hasn't show how are you stephen
a smith
what's going on rich how you doing man
oh better for talking to you
better for talking to you i just have
one question before we continue
please please um have you have you
spotted michael irvin
i mean i i think since since yesterday
afternoon i've had an apb outcome can't
find him
um i usually can't find him he's usually
very very easy to find yes he is oh but
but but but not when the cowboys lose
suddenly uh he just seems to fly under
the radar he disappeared he's been
hiding
uh i've got an apb out for him just in
case you know just case you spot him
just let him know i've been looking for
well he has been texting with the game
day morning crew
uh this morning we've been going back
and forth on twitter interestingly
enough the cowboys are not the subject
matter
um so potentially he might be texting
from a fetal position if i had to guess
stephen a smith yeah that sounds about
right that sounds about right
so um i i want to i want to talk before
about the actual cowboys your process
stephen a
i mean um uh your process in in coming
up with these videos
um right upon the cowboys uh misery
just piling on um walk me through your
process stephen a smith
these videos well first of all there's
no there's no real process i mean
it hits me it hits me naturally um it's
very impromptu extemporaneous right off
the cuff
yes uh it's nothing planned whatsoever i
will tell you
that the only thing that that i want
people to understand is that
it i understand that the dallas cowboys
seem like
they're the ones directly assaulted by
me it's really not aimed at them
it's aimed at dallas cowboys fans
everywhere i i
sincerely mean from the bottom of my
heart i don't care whether you're young
or old
black white hispanic doesn't matter to
me i think that dallas cowboys fans are
the worst most disgusting most
nauseating fan base in american history
nobody disgusts me more than a cowboy
fan because
they never ever ever take a moment to
smell their own stench
this is a team that hasn't won a super
bowl since 1995
and they walk around like they're the
reigning defending super bowl champions
every single year they can finish a
season
on january 5th it could end at
approximately
7 p.m and by 7 15 and this season might
have been
three and 13 it might have been four and
12 if we're
uh deferring to the past and somehow
some way
within 15 minutes they're like you know
we're gonna win the super bowl next year
right
this is who they are they are just they
are just
absolutely positively disgusting i i
love dak prescott
yes ezekiel elliott was just a stud i
actually am very very fond of jerry
jones i didn't like the fact that there
was an apb
out for him when all of the social
justice issues were propping up and
all that so we can find him for a couple
of months but i i'm
very fond of jerry jones and his son
steven but those damn cowboy fans
i can't stand them and my i think last
year
was the greatest holiday season i've had
in my adult life
when the cowboys lost leading into
thanksgiving to buffalo
and they kept losing all the way through
christmas
i don't know if i've ever enjoyed both
thanksgiving
and christmas more in my entire life
stephen a smith here on the rich eisen
show that deserves a round of applause
i'm applauding uh there's a couple
there's a couple of things i want to
pull out of that though a couple of uh
of strands
to to pull on here first things first
you say there's no there's no process so
you were literally eating uh milk with
uh
drinking milk with cookies and eating
cookies and watching the fourth quarter
that game or did you say
you know what i'm just going to grab the
cookie uh and pan the shot over
no no not at all what happened is that
i'm in l.a
um i'm officially by coastal so i'm in
la about 10 to 12 days a month
okay and while i was out anytime i'm out
here my high school buddy he and i have
been
great friends since since high school
since 1980 and
since early 1980s uh he lives here in
cali
and he has this wonderful wonderful wife
named nina
who always cooks me a home-cooked meal
okay and it's the same meal
every time i show up it's some chicken
wings
some macaroni and cheese some string
beans
all right and i got my lemonade while a
football game is on
and when i finish eating that she always
brings me chocolate chip cookies with my
milk
so at this at this particular moment in
time i'm eating my chocolate chip
cookies and milk
and then the next thing you know the
cleveland browns who were in the midst
blowing a 41-14 lead because dallas
pulled within three
they you know the next thing you know
the cowboys give up the end of round
o'dell beckham jr who scared us from 50
yards for the touchdown
at that particular moment of time was
when i had just started eating my
chocolate chip
cookies with the milk and that's why i
said
let me wait let me let me make this
video right here
it just seems so apropos why would i
turn this down
and that's what i did okay and then now
i've got a dallas cowboy fan here rich
eisen show
social media uh extraordinaire uh grand
maester tj jefferson
um who my condolences to him well tj tj
is he is reasonable i do want to say
that i mean you're right but you did say
five years ago though you were
thoroughly
just like every other cowboy fan that
stephen a has
probably resembled the remarks that he
made okay you know
but i mean nobody feels that way anymore
man
and i don't really i don't think so i
mean yeah did i pick them to win the
super bowl this year
did i mean it no in what way he's like
what way did they feel i just don't see
a whole like
i'm on cowboy's twitter a lot i don't i
see a bunch of angry and annoyed cowboy
fans i don't see cowboys fans like
walking around like
thinking we're the chiefs or something
like yeah what do you think stephen oh
my lord
i don't know you i don't know you and i
don't mean to cast any aspersions on you
as a human being i'm sure you're a very
nice uh
highly intelligent dude and if you when
you're working with my buddy rich eisen
i'm sure
that you're a great guy but for this
particular subject you are a
damn liar no way there is no way
that you can say with a straight face
that you don't run into cowboy fans
thinking like that cowboy fans are the
most
arrogant disgusting oh this appreciating
fan base
you could possibly find you never take a
second to smell your own stuff
and i'm just looking at here you know
one of the great great moments that i
had
yes all right remember 2010 when you
ended up going six
and ten but then those weren't my
favorite years with the cowboys because
i actually liked the cowboys when the
playmaker and emmitt smith and troy
aikman were there something in prime
time came over from san francisco and
all of this other stuff
but here was my favorite moment 2011
2012 2013. not only did the dallas
cowboys finish
eight and eight each season they had the
last game of the regular season with the
division
crown on the line and lost all three
years
to each of the teams in the division one
year was the rescues another year was
the giant of the year with the eagles
now it doesn't get much sweeter than
that
and even then y'all still walk around
we'll be back next year
you you'll see you'll see and it doesn't
matter rich
it doesn't matter whether it's some
young punk it doesn't matter whether
it's somebody
that's middle age that's been around
because they're still living up for
roger starbach and then troy aikman
it could even be stephen a smith landing
at the airport at dfw
and it's an older black woman in her
seventies that comes up to me
i don't like how you talk about my
cowboys and i'm telling you right now
they're gonna win damn it you see now
what am i supposed to do
my mama raised me right i'm not gonna
disrespect my elders like that
especially an elderly lady i'm not gonna
do that
right so i had to sit there while
waiting for my baggage claim
i don't know of anybody in this
profession who can literally lament
that they have been heckled by a 70-plus
year-old black woman but that happened
to me
all because of the cowboys stephen a
smith here on the rich eyes and show and
i have to
i have to call the fight a little bit
here stephen because tj
is also a clipper fan and it's just been
a rough stretch
it's just a rough stretch right now for
him but he's also a sixer fan so
his clippers mess got him doc rivers uh
hopefully to clean up his sixers
how can you be a fan of both tj
uh born and raised in altoona
pennsylvania stephen a
uh moved to l.a 21 years ago hated the
lakers who in my opinion have the worst
fan base you don't live out here all the
time
if you did you would see what i was
saying but on those 10 to 12 days you're
gonna find that out
especially let them win and you're gonna
i think you're gonna flip it
you're gonna say these laker fans who
haven't done anything in almost a decade
are the most obnoxious fan base but
that's another point
you know the los angeles lakers last won
a title
in 2010.
1995
lakers have 16 titles in route to number
17.
the los angeles lake is historically
from the days of george miken
to wilt chamberlain and jerry west and
elgin baylor
to kareem abdul-jabbar and urban magic
johnson and james worthy
to kobe and shaq to kobe
and paul gasol now to lebron
practically every single decade they
have given you
a superstar to root for and they have
been
relevant whereas your cowboys
who call themselves america's team well
someone else called the united states of
america the greatest nation on god's
green earth and most of our eyes
this is what we hear is what we've been
told is what we believe
they are supposed to be the face of
america and they have walked
in mediocrity for a quarter
century how could you possibly prepare
to compare the two
what's that say about the rest of the
nfl though we haven't won a title
since 95 and yet how many teams have
more super bowls in this so what has
everyone else's team been doing
in this in this 25 years that we've been
saying in the 70s you dominated in the
70s
um and first of all you won a couple of
rings you lost to the pittsburgh
steelers on a couple of occasions let's
not forget that
but the other thing is that you know
what you had a good stretch with jimmy
johnson and jerry jones
over that four year period and stuff
where you won three super bowls
i got that but the pretty but but but
basically that's
it you know when you for example when we
talk about america's team do you think
he compared to the new england patriots
well i think i think of course you do no
no that's not even close
that's not even close and by the way
their name is patriots not cowboys but
when you talk about america and
patriotism and things of that nature
the patriots seems more apropos than
cowboys
stephen a smith here on the rich eisen
show i would be remiss
before i let you go if i did not ask you
your thoughts on jimmy butler's
performance and if you think this could
be
a potential series changer
at all stephen a what do you think i
think his his performance was
spectacular i think he deserves a lot of
credit for it it was a phenomenal
performance he showed up to show that i
had a triple double 40
13 and 11. there's no denying that the
flip side to it is that i do still think
that
they are the inferior team if the lakers
make perimeter shots
this series ends in five games they're
lucky they got the one that they got i
just think they're over matched
and even with jimmy butler's greatness i
still think they would have lost the
game if anthony
davis had shown up and act like he
didn't act like he was comatose
i don't know what the hell was wrong
with him last night but in the end if
anthony davis gives you
anything um i don't think miami can beat
this team and i think it ends at five i
originally predicted it would end in six
i'm still hopeful because i can't stand
annihilations and championship rounds by
competitiveness
uh but in the end i think the lakers are
a far superior team
and i think jimmy butler talking the way
that he talked to lebron and then taking
it to lebron the way that he did
because lebron was guarding him a vast
majority of the time in the fourth
quarter
to abuse lebron james like that if you
know anything about lebron james you
should expect him to come back with a
vengeance and make amends
and that's what i suspect they will do
in game four and that's why i think the
lakers will win it no
obviously the the whole conversation
about lebron is about where he stood for
the last 10 seconds of the game
and where he went for the last minute of
last second and a half what
what are your two cents on that subject
steven came across to me is a little bit
it came across to me as a little bit
classless but primarily because it was
him
we've seen byrd walk off the court and
mikhail and those guys without shaking
hands we've seen
uh isaiah thomas and detroit pistons
obviously do so
it would be far worse if the series had
ended
and he walked off that way but knowing
that he's got a game to continue a
couple of games to continue in this
series and they were going to play again
uh tomorrow night and stuff like that i
don't think it's that big of a deal
i think it is a big deal because it's
lebron though lebron is class
personified lebron has been the standard
bearer for quite some time
and the manner in which he has conducted
himself is something that people view
as the model on how to actually do
things
so for him to be away from that and to
do something like that is fine but i do
believe
you know what he said was very very
accurate he was frustrated with his play
it wasn't directed towards the heat or
anything like that and i think it's very
very believable
because jimmy butler busted his you know
what
in game three and it was directly some
of it was with directly with lebron
james guarding him
and so as a result for him to be so
thoroughly outplayed the way he was by
jimmy butler
that is the kind of thing that can
frustrate the greatest player in the
world
who is not custom at all to having it
given to him
the way that jimmy butler gave it to him
last night so it's believable it's easy
to stomach
we can understand it we'll see what
happens in game four stephen a
really appreciate the time uh when i
speak to irv i'll send him
your regards when he comes up for air um
please do you know he's playing that
sermon music when he's preaching
you know because every time he preaches
about the cowboys somehow they don't
answer his prayers
i loved how you chimed in we showed you
we showed your tweet
during nfl game day morning two weeks
ago when erv's take
after beating the falcons was it kept
mike mccarthy
undefeated in dallas i called him out on
that
you you you took straight to your your
thumbs
on your phone and and you rightfully
called him out i mean
it really he he is he he is definitely
out of his mind when it comes to the
cowboys you're right
yes he is yes he is no objectivity
whatsoever
but that's okay that means the pain will
come his way too
um he'll be miserable he will suffer uh
the way he deserves to suffer believing
in these boys and
you know that's the way it'll go that
might i might and tell mike mccarthy to
get a new defensive coordinator by the
way
he this guy just got the job from green
bay and who do you pick as your
defensive coordinator a guy that hadn't
been a defensive coordinator since 2014
by the way when he left the
atlanta falcons he had the 31st ranked
defense he's out of a coordinated job
for six years
and that's the guy you pick to be your
coordinator no wonder dallas is
um well my wife would also be upset if i
didn't say susie says hello stephen hey
so
right right right she's the best i will
do that
and uh and again uh keep the videos
coming those cookies do look delicious
look square they look square to me to be
honest with you i don't know if that's
what it was but they look good they
oh those are great i don't give a damn
how they look they taste delicious
you're the best steven h smith thanks
for calling appreciate it all right guys
right back go cowboys there you go
stephen h smith oh rough look at you
going out the door hey you watched all
the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here